[Musique]
les membres de la commission permanente
du département se sont réunis pour la
présentation des orientations
budgétaires 2020 de la collectivité un
budget marqué par la recentralisation du
rsa dès l'année prochaine
le département de par cette disposition
n'aura plus la gestion du reste à charge
de cette prestation sociale savait que
les discussions avec l'état sont très
difficiles nous avons obtenu un
arbitrage équitable à savoir que
dorénavant nous allons pouvoir
économiser 35 millions d'euros chaque
année à la place de l'étape nous n'avons
payé à la place de l'état c'est 35
millions ça c'est fini
nous allons donc récupérer cette somme
pour réinvestir les champs donc de nos
compétences le département dégage ainsi
de nouvelles marges de manoeuvre en
faveur de ces politiques publiques pour
l'inclusion sociale le développement du
territoire la lutte contre la pauvreté
et l'accompagnement des publics les plus
fragiles nous avons utilisé dans le
domaine de l'éducation par exemple
travaillant sur la lutte contre l'échec
scolaire
nous avons travaillé aussi bien sur
divers sujets de prévention contre les
violences violences faites aux femmes
violence fait pour des enfants les
personnes âgées donc dans tous ces
domaines nous allons récupérer des
marges de manoeuvre quoi aider aussi
notre agriculture qui a besoin d'être
accompagné dans sa mutation dans son
développement et bien sûr sur les
compétences qui sont fortes en matière
de prise en charge du handicap et de la
petite enfance des personnes âgées nous
aurons un peu plus de moyens pour
accompagner les publics les plus
fragiles
nouveauté de ces orientations
budgétaires 2020 la création d'un
nouveau dispositif d'incitation à la
reprise d'activité pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa
une expérimentation unique à la réunion
qui devrait toucher près de 5000
bénéficiaires d'ici les trois prochaines
années
[Musique]